Republican and Democratic conventions
are taking place over the next two weeks
Republican convention this week
Democratic convention next week but even
at this late point in the campaign this
is stunning to me the candidates of both
parties are still trying very hard to
come up with new campaign slogans okay
they're searching for that one slogan
that is going to take them over the top
yeah and they're still trying them out
on crowds hoping that one will really
catch on with the public take a look we
are not going back we are moving this
country forward we believe in ourselves
our greatest days are ahead it's all my
fault
I will kill seven hundred and ten
thousand of jobs I'm offering the same
policies that got us into this mess in
the first place
you're the ones that got down you know I
probably sleep in it almost never in the
same place twice
I know a beautiful home a great
they fly me around Papa John's didn't
build Papa John's Pizza I make me very
good chili I'm responsible for someone's
death honey
we don't have enough money to stay here
we can't stay here baby
[Applause]
what's the best one when you can't stay
here baby
I like I'm responsible for someone's
death
[Laughter]